Genesis 50 verses 15 through 21 when
Joseph's brothers saw that their father
was dead they said what if Joseph should
bear a grudge against us and pay us back
in full for the wrong which he did to
him so they sent a message to Joseph
saying your father charged before he
died saying thus he shall say to Joseph
please forgive I beg you the
transgression of your brothers and their
sin for they did you wrong and now
please forgive the transgression of the
servants of God of your father and
Joseph wept and they spoke to him then
his brothers also came and fell down
before him and said Behold we are your
servants
but Joseph said to them do not be afraid
for am I in God's place and as for you
you meant evil against me but God meant
it for good in order to bring about this
present result to preserve many people
alive so therefore do not be afraid I
will provide for you and your little
ones so he comforted them and spoke
kindly to them we have now entered into
Holy Week according to many churches the
most solemn time of the church year in
this final week before Easter we journey
with Jesus himself and his final week
before his passion and death the Week
starts off with a bang with triumph Palm
Sunday he enters into the city of
Jerusalem on the exultation of the
crowds proclaiming him the rightful heir
of David to the Messiah
Hosanna to the son of David but things
go down pretty quickly from there he
challenges the religious leaders of the
city he calls them out on their
hypocrisy he pronounces prophetic
judgment on them and on the city and he
does all of this claiming to speak with
the authority of God himself it's
interesting we normally associate
preaching effective good preaching with
our Lord Jesus Christ one of the
greatest preachers who ever lived and we
assume that good preaching that is
aligned with God's purposes autumn
matically brings out revival and the
growth of believing communities but in
jesus's case in this final week it has
the opposite effect he alienates his
closest supporters he riles up his
opposition against them he energizes
them to bring him to judgment
now do we not doubt that Jesus spoke the
very words of God that he spoke them
with the authority of God himself and
yet in the night before he was betrayed
and handed over to suffering and death
even his own disciples fled his side in
shame and fear only his father was with
him then interestingly though this is
right where his father wanted him to be
he was living perfectly in his father's
will the whole story progresses were
clear that Jesus is in his father's will
doing exactly what his father wants him
to do again and again the Gospel writers
tell us that Jesus tries to explain to
his disciples that he must suffer before
entering his glory but they cannot see
it indeed the father himself seems to be
hiding it from them on the night before
he died our Lord Himself even asked for
the father to give him another option
but he nevertheless submits his wills to
the father's knowing that his will is
the only good perfect and righteous way
forward because as he knows from the
prophet Isaiah it was God's will to
crush him how can this be how can God
will in the midst of human sin where his
accusers write to want to hand him over
to death was it good that they handed
him over where the Romans just in
sentencing him to death of course not
how do we square God's good will with
the depravity of human fallen choices
the crucifixion of our Lord Jesus Christ
is not the first time this dilemma comes
up in the story of salvation in fact it
comes up many times before and one of
the great early examples in the Old
Testament can be found right in the last
chapter of the book of Genesis the
patriarch Joseph has all the reason in
the world to hate his brothers they have
sold him into slavery when he was a
young boy
for no other reason but they were
envious of him and the suffering that he
was made to endure as a result of that
choice was immense and now here they are
he has arisen to a power to a position
of great power and his brothers are now
come to him recognizing that he has a
lordship over them and they are begging
him to have mercy on them
when Joseph hears this you might think
that he would gloat in this moment of
triumph but it's interesting what he
actually does he weeps he's saddened by
the brokenness which continues to define
his relationship to his brothers he
saddened that they are afraid of him
and so he comforts them and promises to
take care of them and their families but
notice that even as he comforts them he
doesn't deny that what they did to him
was evil but he has learned through his
suffering just what God is capable of
bringing out in the midst of suffering
he says what you have meant for evil God
has meant for good and because he has
seen the power of God to work mighty
reversals in the midst of human despair
he will not now put himself in God's
judgment seat liberated that God Himself
is judge he is free now to love his
brothers to serve them any religion in
the world needs to address the problem
of even suffering if it is going to own
the allegiance of thinking people but
the biblical faith is unique in how it
handles this particular problem we see
that our God is so powerful indeed that
he can use even evil choices of men to
work his good purposes whether the evil
that we experience is the result of our
own willful choices or the choices of
others or whether it's just the result
of living in a world that's groaning
under the curse we know that God is
capable of bringing joy out of pain as
we enter a Holy Week let us not forget
God's power we've seen him do it in the
life of Joseph we have seen him do it
most triumphantly and the life of our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ whether it
be the devil whether it be the world
whether it be our own hearts bent on
evil we know that God can use these
things for his good purposes now of
course we don't always know what God is
up to we usually don't know what God is
up to in these things but we do know
that God can we know more importantly
that God does use all things for good
purposes for those who place their trust
in him so as we make our journey to the
cross in this final week before Easter
let us put our trust in its power the
power of God to redeem even the most
heinous of human evil and misery for his
good purposes and we will find him more
than sufficient for our good